nbc universal's new streaming service
peacock
just launched has all the best
programming including
two of my all-time favorite shows that
very near and dear to my heart
psych all eight seasons two movies
and are you ready ready punky brewster
the best part of all we became blood
sisters
blood sisters use ketchup his blood is
too empty
now make sure you check out punky
brewster streaming right now for free
for free and stay tuned for that all new
punky brewster
but thanks to peacock a few lucky fans
were plucked to meet the stars of the
show
nobody could get him to give that room
up
i'm not nobody i'm punky booster it's so
awesome that we get to meet people who
truly grew up with us
all the things that they're nostalgic
about we're nostalgic
turn your phone like this baby so we can
see you i can't believe this is really
happening
i'm just like obsessed with you guys oh
my god it was really cool
to see kids that were my age especially
uh black girls
look what i still have she's in good
condition
my daughter is obsessed with britain and
she wanted to know what
his favorite treat was they used to take
baby food and then they would rub it on
our
faces everything that they gave brandon
soleil and i tried the challenger
episode
is like my favorite cherry and i were
watching
when the challenger explosion happened i
was so
devastated i always thought i would be
an astronaut i remember when buzz aldrin
walked on the set
and how excited you were your teacher
tells me you'd like to be an astronaut
yeah but you know because of what
happened to this space shuttle
my friends think i'm out of my gourd
astronauts are explorers
and all through history people have
thought that explorers are a little off
their rocker
yeah i never knew where punky ended and
i began we were so cute
why cherry did they keep your name the
same in the show
her name was cherry first my uncle's the
creator of the show but he never wrote
it with the intention of me doing the
job really
he just thought that the name was cool
because it went with pumpkin
and then sherry was like oh no no you're
not letting me do that
after auditioning seven times
the president of nbc was like dude just
give your niece the job she won't go
away
i'm so excited for the new show this is
it different being like adults on set
and the reboot i would find myself in
tears every day i get emotional like
even talking about it
knowing what the original meant to all
of us
i'm actually sitting outside my doctor's
office i'm seven months pregnant right
now
and i was like because i'm not missing
this call when they offer the granny
panties with the ice pack
yes you've got to take people not tell
you that be real
we should do group punky powers
delay and sherry are television royalty
now let's see how psyche fans handle
meeting dule and james
this should be fun i won an arm
wrestling contest against doule so i got
to wear these headphones
that's cold-blooded man hi
oh my god oh my god i don't know what to
say i feel so overwhelmed this is so
cool
sorry for stuff in my face it's just
like we're on the show
you see like it's like my favorite tv
show of all time
the joy that you bring me and my family
i'm gonna try not to get emotional dude
when i was a sophomore in college my mom
passed away unexpectedly
you guys like the show and everything it
was just a huge
way for me to kind of escape reality
we use this show to escape reality too
it's a gift that's been giving to all of
us i couldn't sleep last night because i
was so excited
i had to paint something so i made
shirts for my whole family
it says i've heard it both ways okay
because i i sew and quilt
so i made this i got a dog and my
brother got a dog
and i named my dog gus and he named his
dog shawn you just missed roday's dog
i did have one last thing for you guys
but
for you guys to suck thank you amber
this is the best weird thing that we've
ever done
hopefully this will not be the last one
and we'll have more to bring your way
but in the meantime
rojay why don't you tell them where they
can watch it
one two three
those happy psychos bought a cheer
to my eye excuse me i'm gonna go binge
watch
eight seasons inside right now take care